[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hello.
Thank you, everybody,
for joining.
We're happy to have
you here today.
Please, welcome our
speaker, Ishan Shivanand.
He's going to give a talk on
reversing desensitization.
He has been a meditation
teacher and life coach,
giving meditation retreats
for the past 10 years
all around the world.
And today, he'll be
speaking about the effects
of information overload and
what we can do to mitigate that.
So please welcome Ishan.
[APPLAUSE]
ISHAN SHIVANAND:
Thank you so much.
I salute you.
I salute the god
within all of you.
Thank you so much for being
here, and first of all,
it was very interesting
the introduction,
very heavy words used.
I apologize if my talk
would be a bit simpler.
And basics-- I
believe in two things.
And those two things are--
the most important
thing, if you ask me,
the first being peace and the
second being relaxation, peace
and relaxation.
So on this quest for
these two things,
you and I are sitting here, and
I would like to welcome you all
and thank you from the bottom
of my heart for being here
and listening to me.
I look at all of you smile,
and I would appreciate
if you can smile back.
It would be less scary for me.
So very nice, yes.
I am glowing in pretty faces.
So as I said, peace and--
what was the second?
I forgot.
Relaxation, yes.
Thank you.
And these two things
I feel are the most
important in today's
life, because we can do
anything at all.
We can work, we can study, but
in the end, what is that quest?
We could be imagining of our
favorite show on Netflix,
and there's always
the anticipation
that when the day will come,
when I was sure will come,
and the day it has to
come, what do we feel?
A lot of peace.
And when we are inside that
experience, what do we feel?
A lot of relaxation.
Doesn't matter if the show
is bad or the ending is bad,
but at least the anticipation
got us two things.
What it is?
Peace and relaxation.
Any noble experience that
we are trying to gain--
behind that, you will
find these two friends.
And our objective is to
find them, befriend them,
and sort of learn how to
create them on demand.
Before I begin any further,
this whole concept,
reversing desensitization,
how this came to be?
You see, my good friend here,
Mr. Jay, he and I were talking,
and he said, I
believe you should
do a talk in my most
beautiful company, Google.
And I said, what can I, me being
a man in a frock, teach them?
And we were just
wondering what I
can talk, what we can discuss,
and a very interesting show
was on air.
Have you heard of
"Game of Thrones?"
Yes?
Uh-huh.
You must.
I did not hear,
so it's new to me.
And I was very amazed, you know,
because every spiritual man
is supposed to have a
spiritual book, which
he's supposed to talk about.
So let me be the spiritual
man, who's talking
about George RR Martin's book.
So in that book,
what's most interesting
I found there is this
girl called Arya Stark.
And somehow, she goes
to this place, where
there is the many-faced god.
And this girl is being
trained to change faces.
There is a game called
the Game of Faces.
And it is a very
interesting game.
How it's played is, like,
imagine you and I are sitting.
I am sitting here.
I am the one playing the game.
You would be sitting there.
So I will start
to say something,
and if it sounds like the
truth, if you are convinced
it's the truth, it's fine.
But if you are not convinced
that it's the truth,
you have the opportunity to
whack me [WHACKING NOISE]..
So that's how the
game was played.
Arya Stark was there saying some
lie, which seemed like a lie,
and whenever it seemed like
a lie, [WHACKING NOISE]..
She got whacked.
And then I'm thinking,
this George RR Martin
has copied my life, or the
life which me and so many
of my friends used
to live in India,
because we were already expert
of playing the Game of Faces.
And you know how
we used to play?
In the morning, I would
say to my mother, Mother,
I don't want to go
to school today.
Such a good day.
And she would be like,
[WHACKING NOISE]..
Say that you want
to go to school.
And I'm like, OK, I have to
make my lie little bit more
convincing.
I would go and stand in
the morning assembly,
and if I'd say to
my teacher, I don't
want to stand in the morning
assembly, what would happen?
[WHACKING NOISE]
Not physical, more of
a metaphorical-- you
know what I'm talking about.
And then I realized in
my life, so many times,
I have played this
Game of Faces.
Now, my new teacher is my wife.
So she is teaching me.
How she's teaching--
she'll say, please take me
to the shopping mall, and
I'll say, I don't want to go.
[WHACKING NOISE]
OK, let's go to
the shopping mall.
[WHACKING NOISE]
OK, I really want to take
you to the shopping mall.
You know?
It's like you have to say--
and the beautiful words
of my loving wife are,
I don't want you to do it.
I want you to want to do it.
And that is the
time when I realize
that it's not just Arya Stark.
George RR Martin is copying me.
But the thing with Arya Stark
is that she's an expert.
She's more masterful than me.
She has learned how to
play the Game of Faces
in such a beautiful manner
that like a chameleon,
she can put on a face, and
in the words of Shakespeare,
all the world's a stage.
Arya Stark can be whomever
she wants to, whatever
the situation calls.
And the trouble that happened
with me was sometimes,
while putting on a face, I get
confused that if that is me,
then who am I?
Because so many times
you're talking to people,
and some person is saying,
midlife crisis, or some person
is saying, identity crisis.
And while that
person is saying so,
because maybe somewhere down
the line, he put on a face,
or he had to put on a face.
And in that face, somewhere,
the confusion occurred.
So the moral of the story
is that Game of Faces
is fine, as long as I
know what my real face is,
because if I don't know what
my real face is, then maybe
in these situations, maybe in
the incidences which happen
in my life, I get so confused
or attached or detached
to whatever it is
that is happening,
that I start to lose sight
of my goal or my objective.
And what it does
is that it creates
a form of cognitive dissonance,
and it takes me away
from two of my best friends.
And what were the names
of those two best friends?
Peace and relaxation.
And peace and relaxation
are, then, aware.
So again, I start to
think, and then I'm
looking for something, something
to give me that happiness.
And all the beauty is
that if I'm already aware,
centered, grounded,
in a state of peace,
then even the happiness that I
search will lead to my growth.
Otherwise, it would be
something called hidden trial.
The thing with
hidden trial is there
is a very beautiful concept
that I heard when I was young,
and it is one of the
most beautiful concepts.
Why?
Because it had a
prominent effect on me.
You see, earlier, I
used to have six packs.
After understanding this,
I still have six packs,
but they are well-hidden
somewhere here.
And that beautiful
concept was junk food.
Have you heard of junk food?
Yes, very interesting.
It was a new concept
when I heard of it
and very delicious at that.
Junk food is dependent
upon something that
is called supernormal stimulus.
Supernormal stimulus
is biological responses
that are hardwired into my
nervous system, into my brain.
So for example, if my brain
is wired in such a manner
that I will prefer
a certain taste--
let us assume the taste of
sugar or the taste or salt
or the taste of fat--
then even if I have a
choice of nutritional food,
my brain somehow pulls
me towards these tastes,
so much so that I will
go towards these tastes,
even if it sacrifices the
nutritional properties that I
may gain, if I have to
forfeit these tastes.
So you can take a dish,
and you can take away
all the nutritional properties
that may be in the dish.
And if you just put in
the supernormal stimulus
of those things, which the
biology is attracted towards,
then maybe after
a certain point,
it is the supernormal stimulus
that starts to trigger.
And the problem
with such a trigger
is it can be manipulated,
and again, there
can be deviation,
deletion, and alteration.
Deviation from what?
My goal, because if
there is no peace, then
there is a form of
anxiety, because I
may be eating a lot
of food, but if it
is the junk food
without the nutrition,
then my body will be
in a state of conflict.
In the same manner, if I am
running after a stimulus,
and that stimulus is
a junk food stimulus,
then the lack of
peace creates anxiety,
and I will be
deviated from my goal,
looking for something that is
not bringing me satisfaction.
The second is the deletion.
The deletion is that in myself,
I have the power of creativity.
In myself, I have
the power of balance.
In myself, I have poetry.
It is so beautiful,
the eyes of the poet.
You look at any masterpiece,
and it comes from stone.
Yes or no?
And stones are everywhere.
And imagine, if I
have the creativity,
then if I will look at a stone,
I'm not looking at a stone,
but I am looking at the
masterpiece inside the stone.
And if I have the
capacity to look
at the masterpiece
inside the stone,
then I may very well
end up carving it out.
Yes or no?
And the same stone can be what?
Used as a weapon to throw.
The same stone can be nothing
but a mundane experience, which
is a part of my life,
but the same stone,
if I have the
capacity, has the power
to be converted into a
beautiful masterpiece.
And deletion means that me
having all these stones around
me, yet my eyes cannot see
the beauty that I can create.
And a person who starts
to go towards this space
will realize that he has
the power to carve out,
carve out this beautiful
and phenomenal masterpieces.
And finally, what happens is
if I am lost and not grounded,
it's a very beautiful term.
It's called alteration, but I
like the term, zombification,
because, again, when I was
sitting with my friend, Jay,
he was showing me
another beautiful thing.
Actually, that wasn't beautiful.
Another show-- I don't know
why he likes to show me TV,
educate me.
"The Walking Dead--"
and I learned
something about something
called a zombie.
Have you heard the
term, "zombie?"
For me, it was new.
It was very nice, you
know, this zombie.
And the thing about this zombie
is, one, it is always hungry.
I don't know.
Maybe he needs some
digestion problem or what.
The second thing
about the zombie
is that it always goes
in conformity, the hoard,
like a pack mentality.
And the third thing about a
zombie is it bites somebody,
and that person also
becomes a zombie.
And this made me think
that how very practical
this is, because if there is
alteration from human being
being a human being, then
again, the zombification--
a negative person
starts to have the power
to make other person negative.
Early in the morning,
we are getting up.
We are very happy.
We are driving a car.
We are peaceful,
listening to a nice song.
Suddenly, zombie is
driving next to us.
I don't know why
he's in a bad mood,
but in America, I've seen
nobody honks that much.
In India, we honk a lot.
We are very happy
honking at each other,
but in America, nobody honks.
So if somebody does honk,
it is like an electrocution
experience.
Certainly, there is
so much of current,
and you are like,
why did you honk?
What happened?
And maybe that person
was negative, but now
through that person's
experience, even I am thinking,
what?
Why did he say like this?
Why did he honk?
He was the one who was wrong.
Maybe I should have
given a piece of my mind.
I continue to think,
and I continue
to choreograph situations
and incidences.
Like you watch a
Jackie Chan movie,
and it is so very,
very choreographed,
and all the punches
are choreographed.
So many times, I
look at people that
have been bitten by a
metaphorical zombie,
and they are choreographing
in their head.
If somebody would have told me
this, I would have told this.
And how you can get to
know, it's very beautiful.
Sometimes when
you get in a lift,
look at the person's face.
The person's face is
normal, and inside his head
he's choreographing,
and there'll
be small twitches in his
eyebrows and his lips.
And he's thinking that, why
did, at that time, I not think?
And what has happened
that now my brain, my body
can be utilized to manifest,
to create, to dream, to wish,
to hope?
But where is my brain going?
Choreographing the
zombified moments
that somehow came into my life.
And as I said, even
zombies go in a herd.
The same thing affects
conformity to a human mind.
If I'm listening to four people,
and four people are dancing
to a simple tune,
and if at that time,
I am not centered
in the manner, then
that person, who at that
time, is not grounded,
a person who doesn't
stand for something
can be swayed towards anything.
In India, there's a very
beautiful term called "guru."
Guru means a guide, a
teacher, and it doesn't
need to be a human being.
It can be my principles.
It can be my morality.
It can be my stability.
But what it is
supposed to be is it
is supposed to be my anchor, my
rock, especially in the times
when I am obviously confused.
I don't-- there can be
some times when I am lost.
And if at that
time, a person, you
see he's not there, then five
people, six people, 10 people--
he starts to believe.
He starts to accept,
and he starts
to create a parallel reality.
And hence, to avoid
this zombification,
to avoid these phases,
there has to be a purpose.
And why I say purpose,
you must understand
why there is supposed
to be desensitization.
Because so many times,
we just want to relax.
Yes or no?
You had a hard day,
and we want to forget.
Maybe somebody will say,
it is so nice at that time
to be zombified, to just
sit in front of the TV,
and be lost in that
artistic poetry
that I'm seeing in front of me.
And I want you to understand
the whole point, the purpose,
because I'm not saying this
is good or this is bad.
I am just saying the purpose.
The purpose is simple.
There is relaxation,
and there is numbing.
And numbing is different
than relaxation.
Numbing means when I am lost.
Numbing means when
I do not know,
when I am dependent
upon external chemical
stimulus or external
physical stimulus
or external whatever it may be.
Numbing means when
the dosage has
to increase every single time
to chase that first high.
Numbing is when I am not the
creator, and I am dependent.
Relaxation, on the other hand,
is something very beautiful.
Relaxation means
I have the power.
It is internal.
It is only me, who has
the power to create.
And I am not affected
by that which I see,
because it is I who am the
director and the writer
of my story.
That is peace.
And as I said, the
importance of peace--
there is an old
saying which says,
empty mind, devil's workshop.
Long ago, I was in
Australia, and I
was sitting with a shaman.
He was a very old,
aboriginal shaman.
I don't know what is the precise
term-- the village elder,
the wise ones, you
know, the one who
have that big beard,
sitting next to the fire,
looking precisely what
he's supposed to be.
I don't know.
It was very, very nice,
very, very theatrical,
and I'm sitting
with this wise man.
And he comes to
me, and he's even
talking in those wise manner.
You know, the voice is very
low, and he comes to me,
and he says, "Ishan."
I can't repeat, you know.
Maybe I don't have
that exact quality,
but he was very-- the
stars and the fire.
And he says, "Ishan,
I have to make road,
and there are trees on the road.
So necessity is the
mother of invention,
and hence, my mind
invents an ax.
So I cut the tree,
make the road.
Now, there is no
need for the ax.
And if my mind doesn't
give purpose to the ax,
then my mind will start
creating purposes for the ax.
So now there is no road to
be made, no tree to be cut,
and I am angry, and I have
anger, and I have my ax.
So what is the 2 plus 2?
I am angry with you.
I have anger.
I have my ax.
Let us start thinking about
cutting something else."
And I am looking
at that man, and I
am saying, why are you saying
to me all these things?
I am a very peaceful person.
I've never even held an ax.
He said, "Son, the same
goes for everything in life.
There has to be a purpose,
purpose for your mind,
purpose for your body,
purpose for your work,
purpose for even
your spirituality.
Otherwise, your veganism
will also become cruel."
Because so many times--
I am a vegan, and I am
sitting with somebody,
and that person is
explaining to me,
and he's explaining in
such a forceful manner
that even I am
thinking, brother,
I have been vegan all my life.
Why are you shouting at me?
Even the spirituality
has to have purpose.
And if there is no
purpose, then like the ax,
which was invented
to make roads,
it's the same ax that
can be used for what?
Giving haircuts to people or
whatever you may soon please.
Lack of peace and relaxation and
all technology, all knowledge
is utilized for
singular purpose.
Add the variable of
peace and relaxation,
and the whole knowledge
and technology
can be utilized in a much
more humanistic purpose,
because at that time, we can
start thinking as humanity,
as a whole species.
At that time, we can become
more poetic in our outlook.
And at that time, a
rock is not a rock.
A rock has the power to be what?
A masterpiece.
And to create this piece,
there are a few things
which are the entry point,
a few types of meditations
that I would love to teach
you, if you allow me.
Do I have your kind permission?
You have to nod your
head or say something.
I know I'm very--
whatever you may
say, but reaction.
Give me a reaction, please.
Yes.
The first is a very
dynamic meditation
that I want to teach you.
The second is a very
simple, dharmic meditation
that I want to teach you.
And the third is a very--
a meditation for every
single second of your life.
So there are three
things that I want
to teach you that will help you
in your life to bring these two
best friends so that somewhere
down the line, if we were
playing the Game of Faces,
we can be more proficient.
But more than that, we can
help realize our objective
and slowly move towards that.
And before we go towards the
experiential part of whatever
it is that we talked about,
if there are any questions,
you may ask.
I would love to answer.
And then we may proceed.
Yes.
Now, the spotlight
is on you, and I
will try to sit on this
long chair, which looks very
difficult. But I will manage.
Yes.
Any question?
AUDIENCE: I can at
least start off.
And we talked about this
a little bit earlier.
There is just a lot of--
you talked about purpose.
Life has so many dimensions
and so many purposes.
And throughout the day, we
get through from one context
to another to another, and
this whole notion of things
to keep track of,
things to do, and things
to get done, at some level,
goes away from purpose
and turns into
tactical execution.
So how do you keep track of not
one but the plethora of things
that we need to do in
life, and still make sure
that at the end, we are
moving toward something
that will give us
satisfaction in the long run?
ISHAN SHIVANAND: Have
you heard about dolphins?
Dolphins are the sweetest
creatures that you will see,
and they are so
very inquisitive.
And the thing about dolphin
is that they are mammals.
I did not know this.
I thought everything
in the water is fish.
But apparently, dolphin is not.
And one of the most
complicated things in a dolphin
is that it has to come to
the surface to breathe.
I did not know this.
I thought everything in
the water could breathe.
And it's so very interesting.
You know, my question was, how
does a dolphin go to sleep?
Because if it has to come
to the surface to breathe,
and if it is sleeping, then
imagine if you have to sleep,
and you needed some special
room, where you have to go to,
where only you could breathe.
So how would you sleep?
It's very interesting.
So I went to this place.
There's an island
called Mauritius-- very
beautiful, very nice place.
And I was studying dolphins.
So when the daytime comes,
all these dolphins, they
come near the shore, and they
go into a rhythmic motion.
They are going up.
They are going down.
They're going up.
They're going down.
They're doing like a dance, a
ballet, where they go to sleep.
And just like our chest
expands and contracts,
it goes into a rhythm,
and we are sleeping.
Even the dolphin--
the only difference
is the dolphin comes up, and
then goes down, and sleeping.
And it comes up,
and it goes down.
It's such a beautiful
thing to witness.
And here, the most
important thing
is the dolphin is coming up.
Even though the dolphins'
life is in the water,
the dolphins' kids
are in the water,
the dolphins' food
I'm sure there must
be a [INAUDIBLE]
also somewhere down there.
The dolphins' everything
is inside the water.
Yet where is breath?
Up.
And the thing is we must
learn from the dolphin.
Imagine if the dolphin
says that I have to learn
to be technical and tactical.
I have to learn to
be a strategist,
and in my strategizing,
I have no time at all.
I am so very busy
and so very focused
that I can do 20 things,
but I don't have the time
to go up and breathe.
What is going to happen
with the dolphin?
The dolphin is going to become
anxious, more anxious, and more
anxious.
And then if you are
talking to the dolphin--
again, now I am
being metaphorical--
and the dolphin will be
like, oh, I'm so stressed.
I can't breathe, and I am here.
But I have to work so much.
I have to be so very tactical.
Do you go after 10 minutes
and talk to the dolphin,
and the dolphin says,
life has become very hard.
It's so hard now.
I have nothing to do.
And then you go
after half an hour,
and now the dolphin
is like, [GASPS],,
it's time to go, my friend.
Everything is fine.
Everything is good.
Everything is beautiful,
as long as the dolphin
goes up and breathes.
Similarly, we human beings
are doing so many tasks
in our life, yet there are
some tasks in our life, which
sort of heal us.
And the task can be anything.
For some people,
it is meditation.
For some people, it is
hiking in the woods.
For some people, it
is jumping off cliffs.
Really, I have met people.
For them, meditation
is going woo-ha.
For some people, it is
doing charitable work.
But there are activities,
which heal you,
and there are activities,
which put a strain upon you.
And we as human beings
must learn from dolphin,
and every single day, we must
do that one activity, which
heals us, which
sort of connects us,
which sort of
beautifies us, which
makes us feel one with the
world that is around us.
This is called
realistic meditation,
and realistic meditation
depends upon additions.
Why, I say, it is
realistic meditation
is that one is a meditation
based upon subtractions.
This is the most difficult
type of meditation that exists.
In fact, this meditation
compels a person
to maybe develop obsessive
compulsive disorder.
And a subtractive meditation
is that you will not
think negative.
You will not think negative.
A subtractive meditation is I
tell you that from today, you
will not think about monkeys.
You will not think
about orangutans.
about gorillas.
You may not think
about King Kong.
King Kong is
considered a monkey.
Let us assume it is a monkey.
And now, I tell you, what did
I tell you not to think about?
What is the answer
that is coming?
[INAUDIBLE], my dear.
What?
Monkey.
Yes or no?
And I tell you again, focus.
Don't think about monkey.
Don't think monkeys.
Stop thinking about
monkey right now.
What did I tell you
to not think about?
What?
You were supposed to forget.
Why is it that "Dunston Checks
In" is coming in your head?
This is subtractive.
The second is the
addition-based meditation.
And addition-based meditation is
imagine I have a bottle of ink,
and I need to purify
this bottle of ink.
One is put my hand inside.
Try to clean that bottle of ink.
It will take ages and ages.
The other is take water, keep
putting inside the pot of ink,
the ink will get diluted,
and slowly, it will go away.
So the beautiful thing here,
what I am requesting from you
is you are working
very hard, yes.
Has But the best
thing is if we start
to add a little bit of
more of such activities
that I've mentioned
in your life.
And that addition
can be anything.
If you feel peace while learning
a new language, then every day,
for a few minutes,
that's what it should be.
If you feel very,
very good working out,
then make the additions
of working out.
If you feel very, very nice
sitting in a nice place
contemplating--
I was in Vienna, and in
Vienna, it's very interesting.
I went to this place, where
all these psychologists came,
all of them--
Sigmund Freud, this, that,
the Psychological Society.
And there, I saw it
was such a nice culture
that so many people would just
take a cup of their coffee
and go in the garden, sit
and drink their coffee,
and just contemplate.
And I asked one of them,
gentlemen, what are you doing?
And they said, we are thinking.
And I said, thinking what?
He said, doesn't matter,
because if I think so much,
maybe one or two thoughts will
have a little bit of meaning
or whatever it is.
And then I also said,
looks very good.
I also took a cup of coffee,
and I started to think,
because apparently,
I rely, generally,
usually, mostly,
in fact, certainly,
always, we are not thinking.
We're not rethinking.
We are always being bombarded
by so much stimulus,
so much information.
The moment we are
walking into a shopping
mall, every single brand that
we see is a sort of conditioning
that Pavlov had done
when he was demonstrating
the effects of conditioning
on his canine friend.
Similarly, when we are
walking into a shopping mall,
these are all patterns.
And our brain is trying to
calculate these patterns,
and we are so busy deciphering
the patterns from the patterns
of the past, trying to
give an understanding,
meaningful understanding
of the world around us
that never do we
just sit and think
free thoughts, the creativity.
And I learned this,
that this contemplation
is one of the best form
of meditation, which
we are going to talk about.
But as I said, addition.
And the easiest way of what
this kind gentleman asked
was, be like the dolphin.
Every single day, give yourself.
And that time is
your time, me time,
when I am doing that
activity, which is really,
really benefiting me and making
me extremely, extremely happy.
And that will help
in the long term,
because then, when
you will look back,
you will find that there is one
connection in every single day
that I have lived.
And that is the connection.
That is the growth that I
have brought in my mind.
So yes, dolphin.
Thank you so very much.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: So a lot of times,
I see people who are--
you talked about
peace and relaxation.
And there's a way of being
peaceful and being relaxed
that is put on, that is forced.
And I see people walking
through in that way,
when it's just a covering.
Do you have any--
can you speak to that at all?
ISHAN SHIVANAND: Can
you elaborate, please?
AUDIENCE: Well, I guess in
the context of meditations--
ISHAN SHIVANAND: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --that's
where I see it
the most, because with
certain meditations,
you can very forcefully
force yourself
into a state of
"peace," in quotes.
It's almost peace,
because there's
something underneath, which is
never acknowledged and never
addressed.
ISHAN SHIVANAND: Can I speak?
My friend, Jay, took me
to a Muay Thai class.
I had no idea what Muay Thai is.
Apparently, it's a
place, where people
kick you, punch you,
elbow you, and knee you.
And when I went for the first
time to the Muay Thai class,
the gentleman that was there
told us to do 10 push-ups.
Now, the beauty is I do
only two push-ups every day.
One is when I'm
going down to sleep,
and the other is when I'm
waking up in the morning.
And now, this gentleman is
saying, doing 10 push-ups.
Then, of course, I had no
capacity to do 10 push-ups.
Why?
Because I had never
done them in my life.
And the beauty was I did
two push-ups that day,
and I could feel
them the next day.
But then, the thing about body
is, the thing about our mind
is we are very adaptive.
Our body learns.
If you look at our
self, we didn't
know to drink coffee
when we were born.
It is all acquired behavior.
We learned.
Our body adapted so that we
would learn to drink coffee,
and now, every day
in the morning,
the first thing that we are
saying is, where is coffee?
My love, I want to have you
in my arms and take you.
Because my cells
are asking for it.
My body adapted.
And after just doing
10 days of push-ups,
I could do 20, 30
push-ups at a time,
and I'm so impressed by myself.
Why?
Because my body has adapted.
The same goes for meditation.
Imagine if I look
at Rich Froning,
that CrossFit champion guy.
And I say, this is Rich
Froning, and if he's
doing these CrossFit
workouts, then today, I also
do the same CrossFit workout.
I will do 100 burpees,
200 push-ups, 500 squats.
One, I will not be
able to do them.
Second, if by God's miracle, I'm
even able to do quarter of it,
then for the next 10 days,
I will be on the bed.
The same happens that
I look at Buddha,
or I look at somebody in
the Himalayas, and I say,
this is what I want.
And we can get this, of course.
If our goal is to become
like Gautama Buddha,
then, of course, if
we have perseverance,
then we have the
capacity to get this.
But underline this
word two times--
perseverance.
Because perseverance
and persistence
will help us reach to whichever
goal we are wanting to achieve,
because even when we are
talking about meditation,
and I'm talking about it myself.
The first time when I
also started to meditate,
I would have had a hard day.
And trust me, I kid
you not, I fell asleep.
I was very good meditation,
because I'm falling asleep,
and I'm coming out,
and people are saying,
oh, you were meditating
for one hour.
I'm saying, yes.
Sometimes when I'm meditating,
my knees start to itch,
and then I itch my knee.
And imagine if at that
time, I say to myself,
no, I will meditate.
I will not itch my knee.
What is going to happen?
Will I meditate on myself, or
will I meditate upon the itch?
The thing is perseverance and
persistence makes you grow.
Your body adapts.
Even for meditation, quietness,
peace, and relaxation,
the body adapts.
Just like our body adapts to
tea, our body adapts to peace.
And that is why the start
is very, very important.
The entry is very,
very important
and a little bit forced, yes,
because if you take a gym
membership, you have
to force yourself
to go to the gym every day.
So that little force
in the beginning just
to overcome the
inertia, my friend,
is always there in anything
that you do in your life.
But once the body starts
to adapt to that situation,
then the same things start to
give me a lot of happiness.
I was doing this class.
Again, my friend,
Jay-ji, put me.
There is this thing called Soul
Cycle in San Francisco, where
a lot of spinning is
happening, and they
put nice candle and nice music,
and you're cycling, cycling.
I went early morning, 6:00.
And so many people were
there, and so many people
were enjoying.
They were going with the beat.
They were so very happy.
And I realized that these
people are very, very happy
doing this, because
now their body
has adapted to that happiness.
And seeing their happiness,
even though it was my first day,
even I started to
go, [GROANING]..
Even though nothing was
happening down here,
but at least this was nice.
So you know, force
is not a bad thing,
as long as it's
taking me somewhere,
as long as the result
that I'm getting
is good, as long as my body is
adapting, as long as I'm not
going against my nature,
and as long as every day,
I am growing.
So let me teach
you a few things.
Let us start.
And just like I
could do 30 push-ups
in 10 days, maybe, my friend,
you are Gautama Buddha in 20.
Thank you so very much.
Yes.
Anything else?
OK, so we continue.
As I said, the three
forms of meditation--
the first meditation is
a very simple meditation.
And that meditation
is called sleep.
The first thing
that we need to do
when we are talking about
moving towards the path of peace
and relaxation, the
first thing is sleep.
Do you all sleep in 24 hours?
Please say yes.
Oh, thank you.
Yes, that's nice.
So in this meditation
that is sleep,
first is the preparation
for this meditation.
So for the first
preparation that we
have to do before we
are going to sleep
is one hour before
of whatever time
it is that you are
wanting to go to sleep,
I want you to switch
off your smart devices.
And I know I'm
sitting in Google.
I am so sorry Google.
You are the best, but
still, one hour before you
go to sleep, no
phones, no screens,
no sort of light pollution.
What this will do is this
will start preparing us.
This will start
preparing your brain
to now slowly go into that
deep level of relaxation,
because sleep--
we all sleep-- but one
is asleep when we wake up
happy, and other is the sleep
when we wake up like Dracula.
So what we want is we want
a high quality of sleep.
So the first thing that we do
is that we switch off everything
one hour before our sleep.
We let our body sort of
detox from technology.
Another thing that
you can try if you
are physically very,
very able, do not
eat cooked food at
least two to three hours
before you are going to sleep.
If you are medically
able, physically able,
you have the capacity,
don't take cooked food.
Give your biology time
to digest whatever
it is that we've already put.
Give yourself the
power to sort of focus
in rebuilding yourself,
rather than digesting whatever
has been put inside you.
And finally, 10 minutes
before you go to sleep,
it is a very wonderful
exercise that I want
you to do that will help you.
This, we call it
the golden book.
The golden book is we
sort of make a journal,
and in that journal, we write
three things every night.
One is, what is it
that I want from life?
And this is a contemplation.
You don't have to just write
Maserati or Lamborghini.
Just think.
You don't have to write the
lyrics of Desiigner's "Panda,"
another song my friend
had made me listen to.
Very nice.
We have to think, what
is it we want from life?
Second, what will be get
it, if we get whatever
object that we are seeking?
What would be the
change in my life,
if I get whatever
it is that I am
seeking through my hard work?
For example, even if you
are seeking a Maserati
from your life, the
next thing that you
must write in that
book is, what is
it that I will get if I have a
Maserati sitting in my garage?
And the final thing
that you must write
is, what is the price
I am willing to pay?
And by the price I'm
willing to pay, what is
the hard work that I will do?
How many hours I will put
on achieving that goal?
You know, you're sort
of making a ledger.
I will repeat,
the first thing we
will write in that
book, what it is
that you want from your life.
The second is, what will you
get, if you have achieved?
And finally, what is the
price you're going to pay?
And I want you to contemplate
before you write it.
Let there be no stimulus at
that time, no TV, no radio, no
whatever it is that you
consider a stimulus.
And for five minutes, just
think, contemplate, and write.
And this you must do
every night, because you
will find as your
consciousness changes,
as your incidences
in life changes,
as your growth changes,
even the things that you
are seeking from life may change
from a Monday to a Friday.
So you contemplate.
You write.
Then you shut that book, and
you put it next to your bed.
And then comes the second
form of meditation,
which will help us in our sleep.
And this is called sort of
like a relaxing meditation.
And how you will do that, you
will just close your eyes.
Let us try.
Close your eyes.
You will try to sit
straight, and if you are not
able to sit straight, you will
just relaxingly lie down so
that you are straight.
No need to lie down here.
This is for the nighttime.
And then, you will
start breathing.
But your breathing will be
like dolphin, each breath
helping you connect to that
happy place that is within you.
And there is a
physical difference
that I want you to
bring in yourself when
you are breathing.
The first is I want your
breath to be deep, as
deep as your breath can be.
The second is I want your
breath to be continuous.
Let there be no difference
and no space between inhaling
and exhaling.
And the third and the
most important thing--
try to listen to the sound
of your breath, deep breath,
continuous breath, and just
little bit loud breath.
Try.
Inhale.
[INHALING AND EXHALING DEEPLY]
Continue.
And as I said, just
these three things
are most important-- deep
breath, continuous breath,
and just listen to the
sound of your breath.
Try to close your
eyes, and just breathe.
It's very simple.
But trust me.
It is the simplest things in
life that matter the most.
These are the things we
may take for granted,
but something as simple as the
sunlight is the most important
in our living.
The same is with the breath.
Just breathe, and
expand, and contract.
Imagine yourself like a
balloon, a big balloon.
And you are expanding
and contracting.
Deep breath, continuous breath,
and the sound of the breath.
And at the same time,
create another intention,
as if when you are breathing,
you are not breathing just air.
You are breathing energy, as
if air in itself is energy.
And you are inhaling
the energy, and you
are exhaling the energy.
Bring one more intention that
as you are becoming aware of air
as energy, how does your mind
perceive the concept of energy?
Is it like electricity?
Is it like air?
Is it like water?
Is it a fluid?
Is it an object?
Whatever it is, let
yourself be filled,
and let yourself be empty.
Be aware of your
thoughts at this time.
Be aware of all your
feelings and perceptions.
Be aware of all
your five senses.
And let your breath
now be slower.
But as I said, deep, continuous,
and the sound of your breath.
Relax.
Slowly, open your eyes,
and once again, look at me.
How are you feeling?
See?
Relaxed.
So very nice.
And the third thing
that I want you to do
is when you wake up,
the first thing when
you wake up, go into the sun, in
front of a window, if you have
grass, very nice, if you have
a penthouse, awesome, anywhere
where you can be under the
sky, and you can be in the sun,
or if your feet can
be on the grass.
It's very, very important
that we expose ourselves
to nature a little bit.
I have seen that when I'm
talking about meditation,
and I'm making people
meditate on hard wooden chairs
in a nice AC hall, then
it is a bit difficult.
And a few weeks ago,
I was in Austria,
and we were in the Alps, in the
nice mountains, on the grass.
And I found it
was so very easier
for me to make people meditate.
But I'm not saying
that's always--
in Alps, only that meditation
can be done, or in Himalayas.
The thing was the nature.
And the nature sort of--
I don't know what it does.
It gives you a form of
grounding, so to speak,
or a form of connection, which
is a very beautiful experience,
because imagine if we start
to think ourselves as atoms.
One is, we are human body.
Human body can be male, female.
Human body can be
Indian, American.
Human body can be I don't
know, so many things.
But then you'll
start to go within.
You start to think of
the human body as cells.
Now, the thing with the cells
is that a cell can be healthy.
A cell can be sick--
so many differences,
so many variations.
But when suddenly, you
start to meditating,
you will start observing
after a certain point,
something happens.
Some feeling comes
on the surface,
and you start to perceive
the human body as atoms,
as vibration, as frequency.
And the most
beautiful part of this
is not that it is a very
holistic experience.
The most beautiful
part of this is
it is the oneness, because
at that vibration that you
are feeling, there is no man.
There is no woman.
There is no health.
There is no sickness.
That is just a vibration.
There is a sense of peace,
and you are in the grass,
and you can feel that light, and
it is such a creative feeling
that I am feeling as if I
am absorbed in that setting,
in that environment.
And I feel very powerful,
because at that certain point,
it is only that feeling,
and there is no restriction.
And you must have felt this
feeling somewhere at some point
of your life, and
you were completely
part of whatever it
was that was happening.
And it was such a
feeling of high.
Maybe when your project
sort of shot into the sky,
or maybe when a surprise
party was given.
Or maybe there was
this excellent ending
to this excellent movie
that you had seen,
or maybe the first time when you
fell in love, when time stops
still, and there is nobody.
There is no cell.
There is just the
energy, the frequency.
And I want you to
think right now.
When was the last
time that you had
felt something so very awesome?
And what I want you to do early
morning or whatever or morning
or whatever afternoon
or evening you get up--
I don't know.
Not judging.
Your day starts when you get up.
The moment you get up, the first
five minutes or 10 minutes,
just give to yourself.
Go in this nice setting.
If not, you are in an apartment.
Make a few [INAUDIBLE] trees.
I don't know what, just so that
you are near some greenery.
And you are sitting, and once
again, what you are going to do
is you are going to close
your eyes, just like you're
going to do right now.
And you're going
to sit straight.
Now, you will sit straight.
Both your hands will
be on your knees,
and your eyes will be
closed-- very important,
because the moment
you close your eyes,
you become more aware of what
is happening inside of you.
And the moment your
eyes are closed,
you will take your awareness
to the feeling of the most
happiness that you have
ever had in your life.
I'm not telling the situation.
But you may use the situation
to connect to that feeling, when
you were feeling very happy,
as if you were peacefully high,
when you were in that state
of ecstasy, achievement,
when you were triumphant.
Not the situation-- be
aware of the feeling.
And when you are
in that feeling,
just bring a simple intention.
I am good.
And I thank myself for all
that I'm going to achieve.
Just a very simple thought--
I am good.
And I thank myself for all that
I am going to achieve today.
And once again,
your breath is going
to be very deep,
continuous, and loud.
Your breath so deep that you
are breathing until the time you
cannot inhale, and you are
exhaling to the point you
cannot exhale, so continuous
that there is not even
a millisecond of gap between
the inhalation and exhalation,
and so loud that you should
be able to hear the sound
of your breath as it goes
in and as it comes out.
Feel the breath on your
nostrils, through the nose,
through the windpipe going
in, and feel it as you exhale,
coming out through
the nose to your lips.
And slowly, being lost.
In just five minutes of
being completely aware
of your breath
and your thoughts,
your thoughts may rise up and
down like waves on the ocean.
But it is all right.
Just witness, and just breathe.
Now, increase the intensity of
your breath a little bit more.
Just like in the nighttime,
you are letting your breath
relax more and more.
Now, you will increase
the intensity little
by every minute--
10%, 20%, and by intensity, I
mean the depth of the breath
and the speed of the breath.
Let it be more than before.
Continue.
Excellent.
Now, at least 30 times more
powerful than what it was.
The speed to whatever it
is that is comfortable,
the strength to whatever
it is that is comfortable,
and a simple thought that I
am grateful to myself for all
that I'm going to achieve.
Excellent.
Relax.
Open your eyes.
Smile.
Try smiling.
Smiling is nice.
Yes.
How are you feeling?
Say, I'm feeling very good.
Saying that I'm feeling
good is half the battle won.
How are you feeling?
Please say it.
Let me hear you.
Yes, I am feeling good, and
I thank myself for all the
better that I am
going to achieve.
Finally, in the end,
what I would like to say
is we are living a
life of patterns.
And when we live our
life, we can either
reinforce our old patterns,
or we can create new patterns.
Living a life, as I said, of
not being aware of the goal
and being away from
peace and relaxation
reinforces the previous patterns
that we make in our life.
And the pattern can be anything.
I cannot love the
way I used to love.
I was more motivated
when I was younger.
I do not know--
whatever pattern
that we have made.
And through our choices and
our decisions and our actions,
you can only do
things in your life.
Trust me, there is nothing else.
One is we can
reinforce the patterns,
or we have the power
to start creating what?
New patterns.
Of course, I can do
push-ups, but if I
don't do push-ups,
then every day,
I am reinforcing
the pattern of what?
That I can't do or cannot--
please mind my English.
It is not my first language.
I cannot do push-ups.
The second thing that I can do--
start doing one push-up today
so that tomorrow, I can
create a new pattern.
Why?
Because my body
is very adaptable.
My body is very
beautiful, and my body
is very sensitive to growth.
And if I choose
to reinvent, then
I have the power
and the capacity
to upgrade my inner software
in such a fantastic manner
that every day, I am
creating new patterns
in which to live my life.
But these patterns are
not the numbing patterns,
but the relaxing and
the peaceful patterns.
And the beginning
is, the start is
the three things that I said.
The first thing-- one are
before you go to sleep,
no electronics.
Let's start.
Let's see what happens.
15 minutes before
you go to sleep,
take out your golden
book, per se, and write.
What is it I want?
Why do I want it?
What will I get, if I get it?
And what is the price
I'm going to pay?
Five minutes before
I go to sleep,
I just relax, and
I just contemplate,
and I just connect
with my breath,
and my breath, the three
most important things--
deep, continuous, and little bit
so that your breath is acting
like white noise for yourself.
And finally, when you get up,
take out the time to go out,
and at least five, 10 minutes,
again, this breath, awareness
of this breath, awareness of the
thought, and the contemplation,
and at the same time, I am good.
And I thank myself for all
the time going to achieve.
Why?
Because you see our
bodies are so very simple.
And final experiment on
how simple our body is--
my friend, Jay,
took me to a place--
I don't know where--
where they give you two
cookies, vegan cookies.
And they put very nice ice
cream in between the cookie.
It is the most
fantastic alliance
I have ever seen since
the sun and the moon.
I never had thought-- have
you ever eaten cookie and ice
cream?
Yes or no?
All of you?
No.
If you haven't, what have
you done with your life?
So what I want you to do is
imagine that cookie and ice
cream of your most favorite
cookie that you have ever eaten
and the most favorite ice cream
that you have ever imagined,
and put it in front of you.
And maybe the cookies
are hot and gooey,
fresh out of the oven.
And the ice cream is cold.
And both of them are
sort of together,
and you put them in your mouth.
And when you put
them in your mouth,
you are biting into the
cookie, and the cookie
is mixing with the ice cream.
And it slowly starts to
swirl and merge into one,
and then you inhale
and take it inside.
And then-- forget about then.
What I want to ask you--
how many people's mouths
start to water when I explain
the cookie and the ice cream?
Was there a little bit
of saliva in your mouth?
Yes or no?
If yes, you are human.
If not, I don't know
which planet you are from.
But imagine this is how simple
and beautiful our mind is.
There is no cookie and ice
cream, at least not here,
not right now.
I am not that kind
of a monk, who
will do like this and
cookie and ice cream.
And your mind knows there is
no cookie and ice cream yet.
Your mind salivates as
if it is about to come.
Yes or no?
Tell me, my dear, reciprocate.
So if your mind can drool to an
imaginary cookie and ice cream,
then I want you to imagine
how many of your reactions
are to imaginary stimuluses
or stimulants or--
I don't know.
You get it.
And that is why if
our reactions are
going to be so many
imaginary stimulants,
then why not somewhere
I start to tell myself
that I thank myself for all
that I am going to achieve?
Maybe that peace will give
me the power to work hard,
and maybe, in
time, truly achieve
whatever it is I am capable of.
And the final thing
that I can request
to you is one of the
most powerful tools
is the most active
form of meditation
and sometimes the toughest.
Do I have permission
from you to share?
This is the secret ingredient.
This is the chemical
X used by professor
to make Power Puff Girls.
This is the most important Kung
Fu Panda dragon scroll secret
that I'm about to tell you.
And the secret is--
in fact, it's not a secret.
It's something that
sort of helps me,
may help you, a form
of active meditation.
And the secret is I
want you to learn to--
drum roll-- smile.
It's very beautiful.
Try.
Smile.
Try, please.
Yes.
All of you, smile.
And how you will practice
this, the first thing you'll
do when you go early
in the morning,
you will look in the mirror.
And what you are going to
do is look at whatever face
you are seeing, and you
will smile at that person
that you are awesome.
Can you do that?
I want you to try.
Trust me.
It is the most
fantastic thing when
you are looking in the mirror
and not pulling in your stomach
and not thinking how I would
look if this would happen
or that would happen or if
I was fairer or I was darker
or if my hair was longer
or lesser, or I don't know.
Just look at the person you
see in the mirror, and say,
you are awesome.
And then continue
to practice this.
When you are driving,
somebody looks at you
while you are
driving, no need to--
try.
Let's see what happens.
Maybe that person smiles back.
Maybe that person gives you
some universal gestures.
How do I care?
But I am not smiling
for that person.
I am smiling,
because my brain is
so simple that if I look
at imaginary cookie,
my brain drools.
And if I give my brain a
conditioning to be happy,
then trust me.
My brain do not know it
is such a simple thing.
My biology don't know.
It thinks the cookie is real,
and that will give me the power
to focus, to function in the
most appropriate and beautiful
manner.
Maybe the easiest way to
break the desensitization,
and be in the moment
of where you are
is accepting that I am good.
And finally, I thank myself for
all the time going to achieve.
So I thank all of you,
and I smile at all of you.
And I hope you are
happy listening
to what I had to share.
And I hope that all of you find
the real happiness, but most
of all, the peace
and relaxation that
are the most beautiful
forms of human existence.
And I hope, and I
wish that all of you
feel the euphoria that
I was talking about--
maybe in your work, maybe
in your relationships,
maybe in whichever form
you wish to experience it,
because I believe we, humanity,
are a collective consciousness.
And if all of us are
resonating at a high frequency,
then the whole planet is healed.
And even if a part
of the body is sick,
then the whole body
feels the pain.
In the same manner, even if
part of collective consciousness
is hurt or in pain,
then the whole planet
feels in some
manner or the other.
And that is why I like to talk.
I like to come all
the way from wherever
to here, San Francisco, to
speak to the kind and good
and gentlemen and gentlewomen
that are sitting in front
of me, because I
seek that one day
through our collective
efforts and endurance,
the whole collective
consciousness will
be very, very good.
So thank you.
I thank you, and I
thank the infinity that
resides amongst all of you.
And I hope, and I pray,
and I bless that all of you
achieve all that you seek.
[INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]